foreign [Music] what is happening there citizens
of the reject Nation it is time to start the boys
spin-off Jen V John how are you I am very
excited for this spin-off cert that'll get
better Corey how are you effervescently ready
for Generation V that's right man you're a huge
boys fan over an 06 from the beginning of the end
cannot wait to see what they do with the shared
Universe of boys you know what I can't wait to
see what our audience does when they check out
www.rejacknationshop.com right now John and
I are rocking these shirts who influences the
influencers but we also got this shirt we just
launched this shirt snip snip Ahsoka baby get
it and this one we have and that one and that one
and we've got even more and it is seriously one
of the best ways to support the channel and this
month already has been our most successful month
so thank you guys so much your support means
a lot and especially when it comes to a show
like this which undoubtedly we're probably
gonna get a yellow dollar bill sign the sub
Port is very much appreciated with that in
mind leave a like on this video go ahead
subscribe click the notification Bell because
of course we're going to cover the rest of
genvey and as always following three action
watch along where you single with your copy
of GMB available for super sexual Rejects
at our patreon page to cover some things
exclusively over there with reactional Heights
and Watch Dogs included let's swing into action
foreign
s rip up the history books because in New York
this morning godolcan University All-Star eight
straight a train first African-American on the
world's Premier super team black panther welcome
a train oh which proves what we have been saying
for a long time we live in a post-racism world
there it is this is history don't
smile I'm not you have to do it
like Kendall he goes clubbing
with Jake Paul and Scott Disick
delete it [Music]
power power let me get you some Pepto yeah
it really is fine yeah I should
give like birth to Super beings
I'm so comfortable right now I'm so terrified
of how this debuts this is a room I belong in
I'm fine oh wow oh my god oh jeez [Music]
oh no did it just yeah oh no you know it did
oh girl
oh no
God oh no
oh [Music] Iceman and Carrie that's already such a
moment for a teenage girl yeah they
just made it better she won't forget
couldn't even have five minutes
of Sweetness in this world
I'm a bad [__] and I got bad anxiety ever
since Starlight left the seven I've just been
inspired to speak my own truth with all the
boundaries right and that's just me being real
okay so this is the timeline before and now it's
present to the boys after boy season three okay
her story
this guy the only author in this universe
that's cool she has blood bending Powers what
everyone wants blood bending I'll take it that's
a Legend of Korra reference for y'all well Avatar
oh that's always the Palm it's all fake YouTube
naked beautiful
I just realized I didn't
even see the trailer for this
she's like a Morlock but how fast
does she regenerate blood yeah she
gonna blackout does she need to be eating
red meat always oh yeah that's oof oh wow
it's like an old school Wolverine power
like it hurts every time yeah oh no
she's gonna come back later
Ah that's a call back we've seen that video before
[Music]
wow just fries right I mean it's a full ride
wouldn't be surprised if you ended up protecting a
city one day I think you meant to say first black
woman in the seven that's exactly what I hope for
you but a god you graduate you could wipe all
that clean and start fresh so don't [__] it up
God you the center she's at did they explore that
and the boys diabolical I'm Dean Indira Shetty
welcome to godalkin University see the
woman from Game of Thrones I think so
curriculum such as hero ethics and
understanding branding the Beast guy
alumni include stars from such shows
as Riverdale Pretty Little Liars yes
it's like a church of the seven
greatest cities wow oh the Hogwarts
combo with odds magic good oldkin
is a safe space for you to thrive
you're a villain ranked one do that as sinisterly
as possible please so it's like Xavier's School
meets Catholic School meets Hogwarts meets
My Hero Academia Starship Troopers what else
I love that the Vaught branding is so strong but
also like separately the seven branding because
the comics always felt like the world was so
established and this will build out the boys
World by having a show running simultaneously
autographed Maeve merch is it the same day
when I got you whoa so I figured whoa is she
really tiny against the toughest [__] here
yes my gerbil David cruso yes it's about to go
down welcome to fight night uh that dribble Cannon
[Music]
oh this really does feel like a college
show I think it's delighting something
about like the way it's shot right just the
vibe in the music choices not the casting and
the setting the show the literal commercial
for a college are you cool with David cruso
I've never had a pet who's David Caruso
you didn't see Jade who references Jade
so what were you doing um a YouTube show
Fun Size with a little Cricket well I'm kind of
like PewDiePie without the Nazi stuff wowie good
so what are we doing here exactly dude
his workouts are practically the social
event of the season what's up Golden Boy oh
yeah you know when Golden Boy flames on his
clothes burn off Andy's uncut oh he doesn't
have a suit that actually accompanies his
power set not yet I think it's intentional
for him I'm not sweating duh incredible
Steve or anyone that has the in
their name I got 10 grand on damn
I'm sorry
[Applause] [Music]
what is the other guy's power so you just didn't
vote let's say we're opening on a gladiator match
they finally sea cucumber hi Kevin
I'm gonna be down there one day
[Applause]
please tell me he heals does he like the
detachable kid it's like a violent version
of detachable kid yeah all right next
time thanks man yeah oh sportsmanship
can I borrow your phone I don't have one yet
you don't have a phone yet wait are you Amish
blemish
coming to ABC this fall Jordan Lee first of
all you're awesome I signed up for Brinks
freshman intro to crime fighting but it's not
on my schedule what's your name Marie Moreau
you were rejected it's called alliteration
Superior name everyone who majors in crime
fighting takes intro when you're competing
with kids who have cleared homicide cases
who have over a million followers and you
bug ger you don't even have an insta social
media factors into this no I made the call on
his ta who are you to reject me Jordan whoa
God damn it's the fastest throw I've ever seen
they're gonna need to buy me a new shirt professor
sir she I mean he they rejected me from
your intro class they don't know me is
that so it's Clancy we're not a bad guy
I mean inevitably please no I love them
I could go all the way I just I just need the
chance come on old white man performing arts
is a fine program you'd be on Dancing With
the Stars ugh I loved it just like the boys
it's you don't know which way cliche is
gonna go like does that work and get her
in or is it because that show always like
skirts expectations very true very true
oh she's got to do something to go viral oh
yeah I could call oh jeez we got a runner
it's stunts what's going on it's tweaking on meth
oh just regular meth just get old-fashioned meth
plus server Powers equals yes [Music]
leave such a trail it's like scorpion
it's not meth I'm not going
back to the [__] Woods
stay out of the Forbidden Forest it is Hogwarts
I did not think we'd be following him
yeah I thought it would stay a mystery
for a bit what is the woods now we
know Darkness lurks in this world
oh the woods Performing Arts won't be so
bad just trying to make friends like a
normal human what's wrong Performing Arts it's
for all the most annoying people go [Laughter]
an elevated superhero Thing Really a meditation
on Grief told through 70 years of sitcoms and
Zach Braff is directing we're friends so
see yes the most annoying people theater
kids I've seen you in something I did do a
small reoccurring in Chicago Fire hey real
her YouTube channel Little Cricket oh my God
you are so funny holy [__] no that's right
um fun size a little Cricket oh this
is what it's like when I meet actors
I respect who happen to know me fun
sizes Greg and where have I seen you
right here [Music] oh it's that fire girl from
season three Soldier Boys X you remember when
we first met chapter nine of your book
I had to sit on a folding chair in your
folks living room because you kept burning
holes in the front Arnold kid Patrick yeah
name carbide alloy oh concept art yeah no more
showing your balls to America hoping AI didn't
make that what a great thing to do between seasons
of like impact and but you my boy are going to the
seven no draft no nothing the next white guy in
the seven it is interesting to step back into a
world where they have no awareness of how corrupt
and evil the seven actually is yeah yeah there's
an element of tragedy baked in I was coming
up with your superhero name you wanna hear it
bloody Marie oh that's terrible it's kind
of nice a skinny kid you seen them before
the way they dragged them off what about this
bloodline that's right he was out of control
okay coagula that's a great one a few of
us are going on a field trip off campus
Golden Boy myself a few others you should come
let's go Madame plasma breaking curfew I can't
afford the trouble I'm fighting building at
10. if you change your mind you need to learn
to take risks you don't understand the world
ending trouble I'll be in if I'm busted my dad
is really strict I'm gonna be talking off
about this the whole night so if you don't
have anything to wear please borrow
whatever you want from my closet
I like their chemistry together damn girl
glow up I'm Luke I Know Who You Are never
ran it in come on we'll take my car not
the same stuff the other guy was on I
hope they know how to sneak out yeah
it's the gold Porsche subtle oh no
she's on YouTube
let's go get some validation you deserve it I
can't believe I'm at seven Tower let me guess
you were six years old in a mave costume
just dreaming about making this now I do
I didn't even know I had 12. my parents gave me
v as a baby but it didn't hit till puberty oh
they must have been excited no idea I'm sorry
uh I'm lying what my parents died I don't know
why I do that my brother passed away too I'm
sorry but was it similar to or did you just
die he just got sick for my sister I wanna
prove to her that I'm not being a hero is uh
it's not what you think you know if you're
gonna do this make sure you do it for you
because I'm not don't do it for people they cast
so well everybody's so interesting and so quickly
wowie and you stopped at 14. yeah can you try
something yeah you knew it was coming Pete I
don't want you to think I'm weird shriek down
girly supposed to be with the guys I always ask
for at least date two but I wouldn't really work
because like Anatomy he wants her to be the gerbil
this could be fun at it
[Music] [Laughter] I feel it
whoa like the Tom Cruise memes do not turn
her into a Kinks or fetishize her existence
what do our two League girls put up such a
front yeah who in life does that it's not real
oh yes good no take off she's not taking
off she's going right back in there
oh oh my
whoa
so she retains the strength she's
is another size down how do these
powers develop with these specific triggers
okay [Music]
oh my goodness you've ever seen
no I mean yeah relatively ugh
what this must have been like to shoot
actually give us a whole close-up on it
and the pilot a macro that responsibility
and having to work with my dad [__] that
that's all you oh no and I'm proud
of you I love you man what secret
are you harboring what happened to
your brother did you kill him yeah
who's that guy's dad oh [__] someone's
rolling don't you think yeah definitely oh
what's gonna make her bleed
oh God I'm so afraid [Music]
the woods into the woods to
look for trauma [Laughter]
so he was experimented on too huh I wonder
if that skinny guy's brother it's a good
theory maybe he has to take the power from
his brother or something I'm waiting for
my boyfriend fair enough elbow heads I
stay Tales I leave are we dead [Music]
that all the bird can do yes if I can get this
little birdie into his cup who you agreed to
I'd best go home with me and at worst we
hit the dance floor and have a good time
oh I feel like people would
notice that right yep [Music] man
[Music] more Powers is too risky ever we
need to get the [__] out of here now
come on uh oh you guys are
perfect for this episode
yeah oh she's noticing they're not doing
anything heroic come on she's gonna be the
one caught saving hers like saving your mom
go for it [Music] that sound sounds great
bloodbend fall
oh you're gonna go viral oh for
heroics she's alive you could be
A Healer on the seventh you're living everyone's
dream and your roommate's gonna resent you for
going viral too yeah but you're also out this
lady they're gonna let it slide the girl hero
okay in the chair sorry for all the blood on your
clothes oh God worth it oh she's
sweet I know so many people like
Marie right Professor Brinks
office called he wants to see
you oh it's happening just me also I'm
not your assistant get a [__] phone
I've dedicated my life to studying superheroes
I think it's safe to say that I know more about
soups than just about any Soul alive which might
be too good Fred McAllister of Scarborough UK
who's that some powerless schmuck see his old dog
Arnold jumped into the ocean and he started to go
Wonder so Fred he hopped into the drink and he
managed to save his old mutt but can drowned in
the process that's sad that being a hero a real
hero is not about Glory it's about sacrifice
that's serving and protecting there's a way
to manipulate in that way of thinking isn't
there not this guy never sorry I'm to tell you
this but you're being expelled there it is I
was worried when it was positively brought
in Jordan they're going all the way they
could save thousands of people but not if TMZ
finds out that they almost let a woman bleed
to death because they were high somebody's
got to take that hit wow dude I can't go back
send me to this this adult facility that you're
resourceful girl you'll figure something out
man whose blood powers are yours they're
a non-starter in Middle America there's no
four quadrant appeal wow if it's either she's
gonna think she's getting expelled and then no
it's good but when it was good when it was good
I was like just kidding yeah I knew I shouldn't
have gone what happened I didn't ask for this for
you oh leave me alone but but we're coming of age
absolutely
it's not a dream dream it's real damn
please help me he's in the upside down
[Music]
it's also a tricky power because
you leave your DNA everywhere
it's very findable how you feel because I'm
sweating cocaine [Laughter] y'all are the best
oh you're about to see something you're not
supposed to yeah what about me in that room
oh no oh that's what I'm talking about
you don't know about the woods okay
please he fell asleep with a camel
lit in his mouth he burned himself how
would you heard the guy say in the woods
you have to come oh no man
come on damn it dude move
not until you chill out [Music]
and honest you got what do you got
cool
they have different powers in the different
forms speed maybe they're both Wonder Twins
[Laughter] [Music]
oh geez oh
you're going down homelander junior
there's no need to kill them I made my
point should we do this later it's Gotta
Be protocols in the school for violence
cut right to the homelander Statue that's
a journey of where he could be headed he
killed Brink [Music] hey hey take it easy
you know [__] everyone else it's just me and
you you know I love you hmm I've been like this
oh that's tragic was he gonna
I love you please don't burn me
I think he's gonna dispose of himself yeah
I wonder if it's is he gonna self-immolate
wow
flavon's gonna do right now oh
yep yep yep yep
that's a good show
wow too
oh man all right well we got two more episodes
so out so we just want to make these discussions
short um but uh part of me was skeptical about I
didn't even watch the trailer for this part of me
was skeptical about this show that it would just
be something capitalizing on the boys and could
be just be discount boys but it's something very
different and the writing and quality and acting
is just as good yeah it's well deserves to be
a like a companion piece to the boys this is
really really really great stuff yeah I I love
for a first episode I love that a lot that was
that was excellent I'm I'm very much interested
in uh I mean obviously you know the boys has the
freshness of an introduction of a new world and
whatever but I love the kind of characters we're
choosing to focus on and sure we got a mystery
that is I'm looking forward to unraveling it but
the way they toy around with like certain cliches
and directions you think it'll go they know how
to mislead and misdirect uh really well done
but I'm very much invested in our main Central
character uh God that was uh that was really
well done guys all right everyone let's move on
managers got his opinions in and uh you guys are
here just a little bit let us know in the comments
what you think of Greg's video do you agree with
Greg you disagree with Greg let us know thumbs
up for Greg um Juan say something deep oh hey
well I mean yeah this is a day and age wherein
I almost always now greet any sort of spin-off
or expansion of successful you know franchise
core with a bit of skepticism just because there
are so many things that feel like watered down you
know tributes to the thing we all love but I think
this is a really wonderfully pitched show so far
in that you know the boys is looking at all this
from inside the machine and from an eye line that
is you know more at eye level with the machine
whereas this gives you an opportunity to explore a
world like this with the implications it has from
the shadow beneath the machine and I think that's
a really cool thing and then you know everything
else I think you know the characters they've laid
out here are interesting and appealing the
acting is great and this just went places in
a first episode I wasn't expecting it took me
by surprise just as much as there are moments
where you're like sitting there going okay well if
this is going to be positive reception or negative
reception it's going to go the opposite way you
know there are things beyond that where I was like
wow I was not expecting them to go as hard or
for certain things to play out this way and now
you know it's like there's that whole new sense
of Discovery from episode two of like who who's
Really Gonna Be The Ensemble of this thing aside
from you know our main character and Marie and I
assume Cricket is going to come back in some way
yeah um but yeah no this was a really striking
action looks good you know for the most part there
were a couple action moments where I was like okay
this is a bit like a TV editing fight but for
the most part when that's the boys you sure but
uh but when it counts and when they do their big
crazies spectacular moments those always hit and
yeah the power is very striking all that good
stuff main girl kind of reminds me a bit of a
placement of Starlight where she's in a journey
of discovering just uh how much disillusionment
there is in the universe she wishes to live in
but it's also like a form of escapism yeah for
her to hide from her from her pain you know but
it I I think you could draw a lot of peril it's
interesting how when you look at the boys season
one the first super that we followed was Starlight
yeah a long smear but then you know of course
you're following Huey's Journey but following
Starlight where both were like oh I want to
be part of the seven and I have this certain
certain sort of vision of what it means to be a
superhero and they both seem like their purpose
is to be part of the seven that that is what what
will Define them and make them their greatest self
uh where but their backgrounds are very different
you know hers is a bit like Rogue yeah yeah
from X-Men 2000 uh yes Anna pack when the only
road that they only wrote that effort is the
Last Stand take it away koi monologue okay a
few different things hit me immediately one
I actually came from the other perspective I
didn't watch the trailer but because I didn't
want to know the tone because I trust in Kripke
and Goldberg and what they've done so far with
the boys I didn't even know that they developed it
oh really I thought there was like a whole new oh
I followed the trades like hard on this yeah so
I I avoided footage but for the opposite reason
um I'm a bit inundated with this spin-off culture
and like the obviously the barrage of superhero
content I like most of it I like a little over
half of it but I like a lot of it and I think
overall it's hard when there's so much of it to
find fresh ways but I thought if anyone could make
a spin-off it'd be the boys team so since I knew I
think I was more optimistic but I likewise avoided
it because I knew that I trusted them to do what I
thought they would and this is actually exceeding
that expectation because the boys to me was the
exact right time to make a show that played with
what the comics were doing back in 06 which was
that was when team books were really popular that
was when it was like the crash of the 90s led to
this big surge of new comics in the early 2000s
like the Ultimate Universe and that led to a lot
of big team books being commentaries on the team
worlds of DC and Marvel right you had like the
authority we're gonna get soon and you had all
these like almost superhero superhero teams so the
boys was really jarring and that it was like okay
how do we do a commentary in a new way and it was
like let's just see how far we can go and it was
just hit the homers of of violence and depravity
and it was really swinging for those fences so
I think what they did really well with the boys
was it came out at the exact right time of okay
we have established superheroes are popular
and how do you do a commentary on popularity
and subvert those expectations without seeming
like you're just doing what everyone else is
doing with parody and I think the boys did it by
addressing uh capitalism by addressing basically
the Amazon of it all with vot by addressing
the political nature of homelander by doing
all those things and I was like how do you do that
with a spin-off culture and I think what I find
most interesting about this show is with the boys
there's this whole nest of world where you meet a
barrage of characters per issue some issues feel
like they're uh Justice League sometimes it feels
like specifically Batman and Robin sometimes it
feels like this and I was hoping the show would
capture the feeling of you immediately have to
be endeared to these characters you immely have
to care about their powers you immediately have
to feel like what they're a commentary on and I
was worried we would be wanting just the seven so
what they did here genius to me is they make sure
the seven is this overarching paranoia and like
drama saying the inside the the system the machine
and then from the outside but they're making it
from a younger perspective so you're looking up
at the thing that we were commenting on looking
up at the thing the first season but whereas I
find the boys is a great commentary on a lot of a
little bit more right-leaning ideas and that that
that commentary of power and Fascism and those
things this is a commentary on what youth culture
sees as this Progressive Movement as being overly
Progressive for the sake of pain entering and in
the first episode they're acknowledging a lot of
the things a lot of these companies are doing to
like look how good we're doing and acknowledging
so this is kind of going at the other angle from
like that one's taking Jabs the right and left
some this one's taking the Jabs at the left and
the right sum but it's coming from a younger
looking up perspective versus The Authority
looking down all while tying in the world and
making it a more immersive world so I think not
only is this a great way to build out the world of
the boys I've mentioned a few times in the episode
it's a really great like between Seasons World
building but it doesn't feel like you have to
watch the boys because it's got this overarching
young different flavor so this is the way to do a
spin-off because it could be its own thing and
I'm so immersed well I think especially with
uh I'm not really familiar with Craig Rosenberg
but knowing some of Eric kripke's work you know
and Evan Goldberg's work something that I think
they can both really capture very well especially
Evan Goldberg's uh prior work as a producer or
writer is you mentioned Youth and this really
captures the you know college adolescence of it
all and that socializing feelings again there's
like there's qualities to it that that that peer
pressure that shyness that coming out of the shell
forming your own identity finding your confidence
amongst others it's like they're they're elements
of our main character that remind me of both
Starlight and Huey from season one yeah kind of
like mix into one and putting them in a collagen
virus which is so approachable because like that's
the character you want to have the eye line for
yeah yeah and I like this sympathetic approach
that they had with the person who's like oh are
they going to be the big super bat but they're
not they're really just someone who has been wrong
in some way it also is why miscalculated decisions
that was cool the boys does that thing and I
mentioned it like twice in this but the boys
is always so good at being like you expected
and even once your three seasons in you think
they can't keep doing that and this pilot had
more surprises than I expected and this pilot
by itself feels like a more of a I I haven't seen
a pilot feel this much like its own like okay now
I'm invested so quickly well you know I think that
there is a lot more I think I think you know when
boys premiered there was a a lot more I call it
um more guile to the way it was done where here
it's just more character storytelling I think
you know what I mean where I think boy is part
of the appeal of it when it first debuted was the
commentary yeah you know how clearly it's bouncing
right off of what you just saw at the multi yeah
that was so clever yeah but it's still character
driven us invested um we're here that's like no
we already know the world that are inhabiting
and the commentary feels very secondary as
opposed to the character Journey like the way
they capture the how haunted our main character
which I feel too do you know her name's Marie
thank you go what's going on John another name
uh Marine Moreau Marie Moreau yeah I like the
island of Dr Morris clever yeah um the way they
capture Marie and how haunted she is by her past
I I think always the way they play with the sound
design the mixture of that man that was cool
throws you into the nightmare of how that she's
always trying to escape now she's always putting
up a front complimented by the the co-leading girl
the the YouTube personality Cricket she feels very
relatable for is because I've just met so many
living in L.A you meet a lot of people like that
where they have that certain type of bubbly um
extroverted personality you're clearly depressed
you can see it no and I I thought that she was
really well fleshed out um as well but yeah no it
it com it's commenting on like influencer culture
oh my God so and that's the the youth looking up
but it feels authentic they didn't have to say sus
like they I actually acted yeah yeah can I say the
d word at the end DIC is that allowed I don't
know YouTube just spell it out okay so I'm also
impressed one of the things the boys comment does
so well is it's it's really gonna try to you or
we can keep in mind I'll say the D in the comics
the D is used very humorously and I really was
impressed at the amount of D used for jokes here
and how it worked like these are these are funny
and this is like that's the type of humor the boys
captures but it was able to do it as a commentary
it didn't feel like it was overdone great use of D
yeah yeah it's funny you're tragic as it should be
yeah man this was this was really this is this
was really cool I really like this a lot let's
watch the second episode all right guys what did
you think about it leave your thoughts down below
be sure to leave a like subscribe thank you to all
I've been checking out some real rejects apparel
we will catch you all on the flippity flip which
is the very next episode see you guys [Music]